My name is Jose Antonio Vargas.
I was born in the Philippines.
I moved to the United States when I was 12.
English was my second language and I learned to speak American...
...by watching "Frasier," "Home Improvement" and "The Golden Girls."
I won the spelling bee in eighth grade by spelling indefatigable.
In high school, I fell in love with journalism.
I started working for my local newspaper, The Mountain View Voice.
Then, I got hired at The Washington Post.
I covered the 2008 presidential campaign from traveling on Hillary Clinton's plane...
...to pheasant hunting with Huckabee.
I interviewed Al Gore for Rolling Stone and profiled Mark Zuckerberg for The New Yorker.
I even won a Pulitzer Prize for covering the Virginia Tech massacre.
At age 16, I rode my bike to the DMV to get my driver's permit.
I brought my green card with me.
The woman at the DMV flipped it around, she leaned over...
...and she whispered, "This is fake, don't come back here again."
I went home and confronted my grandfather.
That was the first time I realized that I'm an undocumented immigrant,...
...what some people call an "illegal."
The first person I told was Mrs. Denny, my choir teacher.
Other members of my underground railroad include Rich Fisher, my high school superintendent,...
...and Pat Hyland, my high school principal.
For more than a decade now, Pat and Rich have been with me every step of the way.
I define American as someone who works really hard.
Someone who's proud to be in this country...
...and wants to contribute to it.
I'm independent.
I pay taxes.
I'm self-sufficient.
I'm an American; I just don't have the right papers.
I take full responsibility for my actions,...
...and I'm sorry for the laws that I broke.
What would you do if you were a choir teacher and found out...
...that a student in your glee club can't travel for competition?
What would you do if you were a high school principal and found out...
...that one of your students can't apply for financial aid?
What would you do if your child's best friend didn't have papers?
As a journalist, I've decided to do what I know best: ask questions.
So let's talk. What would you do?